dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife
imagine that you are a film critic and
you are recording a video review of a
movie
but unfortunately you are not the best
kind of movie critic
and you record it before watching the
movie
but here is the problem you don't really
know if it's going to be
any good so you record this
i'm going to give hereditary a b minus
so far so good nothing too crazy going
on here
however you go in watch the movie and it
turns out to be
amazing so what do we do if we don't
have time to re-record the video
well we grab this ai type in the new
text
and it will give us this i'm gonna give
hereditary an
a plus whoa
what just happened what kind of black
magic
is this well let's look behind the
person
on the blackboard you see some delicious
partial derivatives
and i am starting to think that this
person is not a movie critic
and of course he isn't because this is
joshua benjio
a legendary machine learning researcher
and this was an introduction video where
he says
this and what happened is that it has
been repurposed by this new
deepfake generator ai where we can type
in
anything we wish and out comes a near
perfect result
it synthesizes both the video and audio
content for us
but we are not quite done yet something
is missing
if the movie gets an a plus the gestures
of the subject
also have to reflect that this is a
favorable review
so what do we do maybe add the smile
there
is that possible i'm gonna give
hereditary an a
plus oh yes
there we go amazing let's have a closer
look at one more example
where you can see how easily we can drop
in new text with this editor
why yao or worry over silly items
marvel movies are not cinema now
this is not the first method performing
this task previous techniques typically
required
hours and hours of video of a target
subject
so how much training data does this
require to perform
all this well let's have a look together
look this is not the same footage copy
pasted three times
this is a synthesized video output if we
have
10 minutes of video data from the test
subject
this looks nearly as good has fewer
sharp details
but in return this requires only two and
a half minutes
and here comes the best part if you look
here
you may be able to see the difference
and if you have been holding on to your
paper
so far now squeeze that paper because
synthesizing this
only required 30 seconds of video
footage
of the target subject my goodness
but we are not nearly done yet it can do
more
for instance it can tone up or down
the intensity of gestures to match the
tone
of what is being said look
so how does this wizardry happen
well this new technique improves two
things really well
one is that it can search for phonemes
and other units
better here is an example we crossed out
the word spider
and we wish to use the word fox instead
and it tries to assemble
this word from previous occurrences of
individual sounds
for instance the aux part is available
when the test subject utters the word
box and two it can stitch them together
better than previous methods and surely
this means that since
it needs less data the synthesis must
take a great deal longer
right no not at all the synthesis part
only takes 40 seconds and
even if it couldn't do this so quickly
the performance control aspect where we
can tone the gestures
up or down or add the smile would still
be
an amazing selling point in and of
itself
but no it does all of these things
quickly
and with high quality at the same time
wow i now invite you to look at the
results carefully
and give them a hard time did you find
anything out of ordinary
did you find this believable let me know
in the comments below
the authors of the paper also conducted
a user study
with 110 participants who were asked to
look at 25
videos and say which one they felt was
real
the results showed that the new
technique outperforms previous
techniques
even if they have access to 12 times
more training data
which is absolutely amazing but what is
even better
the longer the video clips were the
better this method fared
what a time to be alive now of course
beyond the many amazing use cases of
deep fakes
in reviving deceased actors creating
beautiful visual art
redubbing movies and more we have to be
vigilant about the fact
that they can also be used for nefarious
purposes
the goal of this video is to let you and
the public know
that these deep fakes can now be created
quickly and
inexpensively and they don't require a
trained scientist anymore
if this can be done it is of utmost
importance that we all know about it
and beyond that whenever they invite me
i inform
key political and military decision
makers about the existence
and details of these techniques to make
sure that they also know about these
and using that knowledge they can make
better decisions for us
you can see me doing that here note that
these talks and consultations all happen
free of charge and if they keep inviting
me i'll keep showing up to help with
this in the future
as a service to the public perceptilabs
is a visual
api for tensorflow carefully designed to
make machine learning
as intuitive as possible this gives you
a faster way to build out models
with more transparency into how your
model is architected
how it performs and how to debug it
look it lets you toggle between the
visual modeler and
the code editor it even generates
visualizations for all the model
variables
and gives you recommendations both
during modeling and training
and does all this automatically i only
wish
i had a tool like this when i was
working on my neural networks during my
phd years
visit perceptilabs.com papers to easily
install
the free local version of their system
today our thanks to perceptilabs for
their support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time